hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast advances in hydrogen deuterium
exchange mass spectrometry that can
improve studies of biosimilars and
membrane protein drug targets it is
presented by Jeffrey Hutchins PhD a
research chemist and IBB our fellow at
the Institute for bioscience and
biotechnology research in the bio
process measurements group of the
biomolecular measurement division at the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology I am Judy O'Rourke of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab Rhodes is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box appears
on the screen our speaker will respond
to your questions via email if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Hudgens I will
now turn the presentation over to him
well thank you for listening to my
webinar I'm going to tell you a little
bit about developments in the field of
hydrogen the term exchange mass
spectrometry as it applies to
biosimilars you may wonder why the
National Institutes of standard
technology which I work with is
interested in this problem and just to
tell you a little bit about the agency
it's an
non regulatory agency within the US
Department of Commerce we don't make any
rules we do make some consensus
standards with industry to help
accelerate industry this is responsible
for the physical standards of the US and
test methods and calibrations we have a
unique mission which is to promote
innovation industrial competitiveness by
advancing measurement science standards
and technology and in particular with
respect to the bio manufacturing its
mission is to develop measurement
science standards reference data and
tools that support the development
manufacturing and regulatory approval of
biologic medicines and this is quite in
line with the talk today the method I'm
going to be talking about is hydrogen
deuterium exchange mass spectrometry HDX
IMS it's been a method that's actually
been around since about 1991 and has
grown rapidly in its in its popularity
as of about a year ago there were
eighteen hundred and sixty refereed
papers these are the original papers
they don't include reviews or anything
and the topics of these papers have
spanned quite a number of things but
about seven percent of them are about
biopharmaceuticals I suspect there's a
dark literature within companies that is
much larger there's membrane proteins
interactions epitope maps protein ligand
work and structural characterization
everything that a that a structural
biologists and biochemists would want to
know about about things so
it's good to me so move that's the the
method has become a regular tool in
structural biology and biochemistry labs
with its visible uses in biopharma of
starting around 2008 there was some
effort to use HDX for a data for
evaluating bio similarity between two
lots of drugs or a lot of the innervate
a drug with a the candidate biosimilar
there's been a little bit of work so on
that sense in an internal memo at FDA
they noted in 2016 the 15 percent of all
drug applications contain HD x ms data
and just a year later i did a search and
found that there's about 110 patents
about some mostly involving biosimilars
or biologics that are they using HDX
data in them as part of their part of
their mechanism of action and that's
worth and those sorts of things in 2017
I learned that there's two companies
that are using HDX MS for quality
control work I'm not going to be talking
about that but it is a little bit
different from what I'm doing here today
but not much the key of of hydrogen
determining screen is that there are
certain and the amat sites of a long
hate protein polymer are all exchanged
at the magic rate which is around a
half-life of 10 seconds to 60 days and
with hydrogen to term exchange mass
spectrum should we can measure that
covalent bonds just simply don't
exchange and the side chains on some on
some amino acids just exchanged at the
millisecond rate so there's simply too
fast
and they don't seem to have much
relevance to do to biopharma anyway the
there a theory of how this works how the
exchange occurs is that most of the time
a protein is in sight is in its closed
form it doesn't interact with solution
it will not exchange and then at certain
times a a perturbation occurs and it
opens a site opens for exchange this is
the amat site that is and when it's open
the you have the the amino acid acts
simply as an acid in base and so it
again undergoes the exchange rate that
is determined by the acid base so and
what time so what this means in total is
that the protein dynamics of the closing
and opening process is modulated by the
higher order structure of the of the
protein polymer and the exchange rate is
just simply an acid base property but
because it modulates that we can we can
study and do some interesting things
with with the method now looking at I
mentioned this has to do with higher
order structure and if you take for
example an alpha helix and it's and it's
in its normal or a completely rest at
lowest energy form and you try and
balance a solvent molecule off of it it
this probably won't display properly but
the result is there's no reaction
there's no exchange because the the the
the amino the the AMEX are involved in
complex ation with oxygen and the energy
to remove that it's just simply not
enough Gibbs energy to remove it but if
the for example the alpha helix is 3
and exchange an extended this occurs in
normal normal fluctuations of the
protein over time it weakens the
hydrogen bond to the oxygen and you can
end up with if now when solvent bounces
off of the exchange can occur this
modulation is acid or base catalyzed and
it occurs mainly in the absence of
strong hydrogen bonding such as when an
alpha helix is stressed and opens it up
for exchange the electrostatic and
hydrophobic interactions also expect
effect exchange rates because they
stabilize they can stabilize the protein
also further against exchange now I
mention that there are there are
actually two types account of catalyst
but there's actually three there's but
there's base catalyzed which occurs at
pH is above are dominated by pH is above
three and ask the catalyze which are
dominated at pH less than three there is
also a slow water catalyzed defense
which is usually not terribly important
but there is a minimum at which the rate
of the exchange is it is neither
Cazadores catalyzed and that occurs from
each amino acid somewhere in the in the
two and a half to four pH range so this
becomes important for our method today
that I'm going to present so here's the
steps of the hydrogen Ettore exchange
experiment you can have two types of
solution you can do this separately
you'd have your protein without any
complex ation or you can have it with a
solution containing the protein Ana
ligand
so that's your a bow is your is your
protein alone and your whole o is your
protein plus ligand and of course thing
will bind so you can take the you you
you take the protein and a here you've
first dunk it into or immerse it into
d2l
in that product that begins a labeling
process in the ambit hydrogen's exchange
of their particular rate with with
deuterium in the water at a given time
you take that solution and you immerse
it into a an ascetic quenching solution
pH 2.5 and you have a denature at which
unwinds your protein and then you inject
that into a probably a proteolytic
column which contains pepsin usually
they can have other pretty protease is
also but usually pepsin is the most
common and this slices up your protein
into peptides the peptides then go
through a well a liquid chromatography
step where they separate and each one of
the peptides comes out at a given time
now given a as shown in the in thing up
in the slide below we do this for
several at several different immersion
times of 0 to say 24 hours and this is 4
hours here and each experiment is met is
measured and you integrate the the sent
to find the centroid mass and I'll talk
about this in a second and then you plot
this out you plot this out I'm gonna on
a graph versus time and you will see a
difference in a po and hollow in April
and hollow in the areas where there is
contact in the protein occurring now one
thing you have to keep in mind and all
of this is that there is a back exchange
process as soon as you quench you're
beginning to do your analysis in water
and the and the great dominance of water
and the solution causes deuterium to be
swapped out for hydrogen again and so
the labeling that you put on to the
protein
begins to begins to fade so I'll talk
more about this problem later because we
have a bit of a solution for it so to
focus a little bit more in as each
peptide immerse comes out of the
chromatography system at a particular
time it will present a mass envelope and
the under the deuterated one will be the
lightest mass and as you see here in the
sequence of Hawaiian fragments spectra
you can see that the center of mass
moves to heavier and heavier mass with
time this is the deuterium be coming
onto the amat site of the the protein in
this particular peptide and you can plot
this again so what does it express the
lab look like the lab looks like has it
has a process robot it has your
chromatography system it has your it has
a reasonably high resolution mass
spectrometer now we use an orbit wrap
actually most laboratories use a time of
flight instrument yeah they're all
they're all good so they're all adequate
for this measurement 20 years ago that
might not have been treat today it's
very hard to find an instrument that
isn't capable of giving you the data you
need now what does I what what is a
typical experiment or one experiment
looked like this is taken from a piece
of work that was on looking at
meningitis and they were developing they
had developed an antibody that that
bound with factor H which decorates body
the cells in your body and protects us
from the innate immune immune system and
so they were looking for the that shown
here in the middle here is the is the
the CDR loops
of the of the of the antibody and shown
here are the sections of peptide which
are showing interaction with the factor
H vector H is the ligand in this case so
that's the whole load and you can see
that there is a that the holo has less
deuterium uptake in the peptide range of
126 to 137 and likewise in the other sub
panels you can see that in each case
these the the peptide say 214 to 233
shows suppressed to cheer him up take in
the complex form and this allowed and
this allows you to map out which loops
of the CDR are actually interacting with
the ligand looking at the looking at
this this study done very nice study
done by Milito a few years ago they
actually use several different ways and
came up with a consensus it's a map of
the binding sites on factor H now what's
shown here in the in the patent in the
center is that in red is the consensus
binding sites that they found and this
is from all methods and the and what's
shown is only the fifth and sixth domain
of the of the factor h protein but which
is where the meningitis attacks they use
phage array which is shown on the left
here and peptide array and they used an
x-ray structure which of course found
the strong interaction and but then they
found they used h DX the interesting
thing about this is that this the red
here is the is the consensus binding is
somewhere between 800 to a thousand
square angstroms and the hydrogen
deuterium exchange experiment captures
that the x-ray structure captures the
strongest interactions but the hydrogen
deuterium exchange actually captures
majority of it
so anyway that that's this this sort of
experiment which looks at it at
ligand-binding it comprises probably
close to 80% of the literature and it's
been used for finding and evaluating
drug leads and other useful other and
mechanisms of actions and other other
signaling events so one of the questions
that you have a of it as though is that
so I've shown you it's time dependent
and we read you read the information out
by looking at peptides and the exchange
rate of each Hammett is a function of
variables that affect the Gibbs energy
of exchange and those are the pH of the
solution the temperature of the solution
the ionic strength of the solution
matters and pressure and so if you're
doing a measurement with so many
variables to keep track of just how
reliable is a hydrogen deuterium
exchange mass spectrometry measurement
we looked at this and this actually is
part of this talk here and the first way
we looked at is we had a student run 20
experiments a day with 30 second
immersions
now this is ubiquitin pepsin and it has
about 76 78 amino acids on which the
sequence that's shown there probably too
small for you to see but the numbers are
shown on the left and when you slice it
up with with with the pepsin protease
the the these bands here are shown in
black just represent the the peptides
that you would see and these peptides
are also seen on the on the graph at the
bottom with their amount of deuterium
that they're that they're taking
now each spot is not one measurement
it's actually 20 measurements for one
day 20 measurements for day 2 and then
20 measurements on day 37 so each dot is
actually
actually 60 measurements and as you can
see there's not a lot of variability
because they lay on top of each other we
can take this and look at the just the
standard deviations only and look at
them for day one and the average
standard deviation of the spots the each
spot represents all the cup all one
peptide and all the measurements done
the 20 measurements done that particular
day and you can see that the average
there is about one percent standard
deviation and the maximum is about one
point eight on day one day two it's a
bit more but it's still about one
percent and day thirty seven is about
the same so you would say that the
repeatability is is about one percent
actually at worst it's it's two percent
and the intermediate measurement
precision is still about one to two
percent this gets into what the the
components of precision are and they are
repeatability which is what you get out
of your lab when you do the measurement
with the same operator same operating
conditions over and over again with the
same equipment your intermediate
measurement precision is the standard
inside the laboratory and so if you keep
track of these in your own work you can
do good work with epitopes studies
single lab in a single lab but if you're
representing something on the outside
you need to know what the measurement
reproducibility is that is if I take a
sack of sack of sugar and measure it in
in in salt lake and I'm gonna take it
down to Houston Texas what will be the
difference in the weight that's what
reproducibility is so the only way you
can return determine the reproducibility
of any method is that you have to send
it out to a lot of different
laboratories and what's the value that
well the value of that is that when you
establish what that reproducibility is
this allows you to understand if
doing multiple experiments in multiple
labs of of how what have the what level
of Correspondence you can expect among
the labs so if you were a drug company
and you had three three different labs
doing the same work on something and you
wanted to compare data then you could
compare the data and the other part of
it is if you're gonna release this
material to commerce for any use in
commerce you need to know this
reproducibility okay to conduct conduct
this reproducibility study we prepared a
Christmas sampler a type of box that
contained some standardized solutions
this was ship cold to 215 laboratories
and the the contents of the solution
were a proteomics proteomics solutions
and then three is the solutions
necessary to do three runs of hydrogen
to form exchange the Descent the main
sample the protein sample was a fab of
miss map which is a standard antibody
that nist issues issues and is widely
available
it's automatically clipped from the FFC
portion and so it may get simplifies the
the the proteomics and the the amount of
data that people got but it still
produces a tremendous amount of data so
the the solutions organize the
experiments that provide all the
glassware and buffers required for
sample preparations most importantly it
conserves the P H and P D and the in the
D to low fraction and one thing that we
found that was very important was
providing the T sup which reduces the
Dyck disulfide bonds and we found that
there's some variation of quality out
there and we wanted everybody to have
the same quality so we ship that
I'm also the whole point of this is that
going back to the experiment and we we
have an environment that's defined by
the kid
during the important labeling and
quenching steps the rest of the
experiment is controlled by the
laboratory and the conditions of their
equipment but the most important part
which is the labeling is controlled by a
standardized environment that we provide
by the carrot so the 15 labs reported
their centroids for their or there are
three runs and that totaled up to eighty
nine thousand eight hundred centroid
measurements as you can see here an in
the explosion exploded view below they
comprise a list of the of the peptide
the peptide identification for it sits
in the protein this is the fab of this
map again protein it's retention time
and then it's it's its weight its
centroid weight at each of them each of
each of the several time frames that we
gave it looking at the whole spreadsheet
it really does look like this only only
Biggers because there's 15 of these so
if you take all of that you can end up
with a repeatability plot for all the
peptides so what this represents is this
is the deviation of for example x 0 or
each group and then time 1 which is
about 30 seconds for each group find 60
seconds out to four hours and then we
also have a control which we call T in
attina equals infinity so but this is
the self-consistency event each
measurement a standard deviation of the
measurement that's what's represented
there and each one of these points on
there
is the standard deviation of all the
peptides or that particular group so
that represents about about a thousand
measurements per point on this ground
the important thing is is that 87% of
the graph of the labs get about 0.15
elton's of precision all the labs get
better than 0.4 this may sound terrible
from a mass accuracy point of view but
remember the average applied that
they're measuring is about a thousand
oversee a 1000 so the Precision's
actually and these are centroids not
mass accuracy in this normal sense of
what a mass spectrometer it measures
okay now if we we want to measure the
reproducibility of the is measurements
this is the difference this would be the
difference between the time 0 in the
time 30 second in time zero in times 60
second fine each time out to four hours
and then you plot each each laboratories
measurements on a graph and six of these
are shown on the left panel here those
are the plots of the back exchange
corrected the uptake versus time for
each of these of the six peptide
sequences that we know that I'm showing
here and this is shown for nine groups
these are the nine groups that worked at
25 degrees C there were other groups and
measured in 21 degrees and at twenty
point six degrees
oh shoot show you that in a second so a
25 degree LabCorp taken together they
get a big in a reproducibility a
standard deviation of about six and a
half percent and that's for 14 peptide
sequences I'm showing left six of them
on the left here it's boring if you look
at too many of them and the one of the
interesting things here is that the
standard deviation is really don't
deviate with time which is nice nice
feature what didn't quite expect that
expected deviation
the other thing is you take all the
other times that temperatures excuse me
and that this takes you through 15
groups the weighted mean of all the
standard deviations indicates that
collaborative reproducibility is about
9% this is a weighted mean derived for
244 peptide sequences and so the
standard deviations and don't deeply
touch with time now you see those little
points up there which 3.6 degrees
they don't really represent a lot of
weight yes
the weighted average really and there's
about 9 percent or better for all this
so what does this running with you this
means that if a naive customer and we
don't say naive in the terms of stupid
we mean naive in the terms of they don't
really know the art of cutting to do
hydrogen deuterium exchange and so they
just go to a service lab it's a measured
me measure me a bunch of peptides for me
and tell me what the reproducibility
what or what what you measure and then
how much how much how much variance
would I expect to see if I took it to
another laboratory and had been measures
say a hundred or two hundred peptides
off of this protein sample what my party
the variance be and that would be nine
about nine percent and of course that's
the distribution so some would be more
and some would be less the repeatability
is what you do when you're doing an APO
holo experiment and what this tells you
by their repeatability seen across the
labs is if you consider a three sigma
difference as being different enough
that would mean the point four or five
dollars is is always significant forum
for measurements when you're looking at
at protein interactions of 800 protein
interactions like an 800 lo sample
experiment this paper actually took a
lot of people a lot of work and it will
be coming out in the next couple months
and so it this is the list of people
there's 37 people on this paper now
let's go to membrane proteins we've done
what I think is a pretty good
contribution to this field and it's
important because 60% of all drug
targets are membrane proteins
the problem with membrane proteins is
that you need to put them into you're
going to study them in vitro you need to
put them on a buy-sell lip a zone or an
ANA desk and then you can study them in
pretty much their native behavior but
the problem with this is that as soon as
you go and you try and do an analysis
would say a c12 column it destroys that
thousand-dollar column very quickly and
the other part of it is is that the the
lipids themselves in the electrospray
they suppress ions so you're not gonna
have very good signals now investigators
know how to deal with us they had
zirconium oxide and do it a manual
Meccan it a manual procedure which
removes the the lipids but they have to
stand for hours in front of an
instrument and do this do and do these
manipulations by hand they this takes
extra time and so they're the data
they're getting is they even by their
own admission say that they wish they
were getting better data because it just
takes a little bit too long to do this
work
so the and the other part of it is is
that if you're if you're a commercial
laboratory you're not probably going to
be doing this technique because it just
takes too much labor and people quite
frankly don't have it have the patience
degree it is type work so what we did is
we took a um the CD 32 FC receptor which
is a membrane proteins a single membrane
protein and it's exactly expressed in
two lipizzans
and collected his exosomes and we did
some experiments to see if we can do
this separation properly
what I have pictured here is is it's an
interaction with the FC I see off of the
ma'am but in fact this is just extra
league the blue part is there you can
see membrane bilayer that it's involved
and you need to remove these fossil from
at a graphic graphic separation so now
on the left here you show is what a
standard experiment without the without
the need to remove the lipids is it's
fairly straightforward next to it is the
differences and with a mechanized method
that we have automated method we have it
adds seventy seconds to the process and
most of that is done at lower
temperature so what this looks like is
that you do your regular hydrogen
deuterium exchange experiment you then
take the solution put it into put it
into a solution with zirconium oxide and
D matrix just as you would normally then
you put you take that and that that cell
that you put it into originally is the
bottom of a crushed overflow and then
you you you put that top on it
push it and the supernatant pops to the
to the filter and you can check that
into your lcms and your lipids are
removed this looks like for a robotic
system such as ours this and it also is
generally available out on the field
this looks pretty simple to do you you
just stock up the drawers as shown here
on the lower right the filter inserts
your exchange that you would have in a
normal experiment every basis is there
which is where your quenches and then
you you just load it across onto the
filter and he's put it into the Express
and then and then um endless take the
supernatant and inject it lets you get
out of this if you do this with the CD
two CD that's 32 a
receptive and this is the this is the
map the peptide map peptide map and HDX
tells you what you can see if you do
iron it and determine shape experiment
because these are the peptides that you
would see and as you can see here the
entire map show isn't mostly in red but
it's about 80% 85% coverage you can even
see some of the transmembrane region
here which is shown this is black bar
here and this is all available for
hydrogen
during exchange experiments it's an
important point is that the addition of
the zirconium oxide does not diminish
the protein iron signal
so therefore putting the zirconium oxide
in is not going to change your is not
going to all your experiment at all and
this method has been published in the in
analytical chemistry back in June and I
believe so in the summary of this work
is that automated hydrogen took care of
exchange of membrane proteins is now
possible and this will allow you to do a
lot more complex experiments and improve
your precision when you're doing
membrane protein dynamics compared to
manual analysis of membrane proteins
automated hydrogen to term exchange
reduces the analysis time by one or two
minutes per sample and this results in
much less back exchange in the data and
the automated hundreds changing membrane
proteins makes extensive studies of
large molecule and small molecule drug
membrane protein interactions visible so
we have a lot of hope that this will
disseminate out indeed by development
person okay for their experiments now I
keep dropping the term back exchange
during this during this presentation and
as the title and in case of scourge of
this method and what batch of exchanges
is that as soon as you start the
analysis you're doing
you go from a d2l water solution and so
you bet you you are losing your
deuterium label this crops the protein
and in a fact it's like like over
developing a photograph and you start
losing features and this this this means
and this effect is is about fifteen
fifty five percent in the in the miss
map study that I just showed you for the
reproducibility the typical peptide that
we saw and somewhere between 15 and 45
percent back exchange so you're losing a
lot of information that you might want
to keep that can we may worse on
particular site being such as mr. Dean
and others because that he even connect
catalyze catalysis corals page and also
the other problem is is that overlapping
Ellucian during the past LC separations
suppress ions you do this these fast
separation because you need to do them
fast because you're losing label and as
a result you passed when you do it that
way you get more overlap and you see or
peptide sequences because and if you
were using longer gradients you get a
number of a lot more identifications of
peptides you get a lot more information
but as I say you're in a race against
time and you're going to use if you if
you use long so we know that if we were
to decrease the temperature say to minus
30 we could reduce the back exchanges by
a factor of 40 well of course water
freezes at zero that's the problem so
here's the computer than measured for a
BAC exchange at zero degrees and the
current recovery practice is about
eighty percent recovery average capacity
or a ten-minute illusion you're talking
about you know 82 percent recovery so 80
82 if you were to take that to minus
twenty and this has been done by mixing
if I call him you can get in the
temporary 10-minute Ellucian at 90 to 95
percent recovery and over here are fewer
and 99 minus 30 you could actually get
95 percent recovery with a 40-minute
illusion right on your chromatic and
your chromatograph so you can separate a
lot more peptides and still your how to
get good term exchange so how do you do
this well I designed an instrument that
runs at minus 30 and it comprises a
stack of six six six pumps it has in
usually si source it has a nine zone
temperature control or devout control of
the usual things that you use and
breaking it out this mounts on a Ray on
the robot rail and you have your
injector point of course the robot does
but instead of one produce column I have
two this allows you to do much more
complex
did I just if you have a go like I'd
like in that you need to remove to get
good digestion you can put a glycol
Siddis column you know the top chamber
and put a toady probably a little column
in the bottom and all the the chamber is
at zero for floating things including
other reducing cell if you need it and
then everything goes on to the guard
column and and and then the the
separations are conducted at minus
thirty so these three chambers run at
different temperatures your main
preparation is at zero or about one
degree your proteolytic can be from zero
to ten and then your actual analytical
analytical steps are done at minus
thirty what that allows you I can't keep
your toe back exchanged to about five
percent he gives you cleaner
chromatography gives you a lot better
accuracy on deuterium measurements and
it also what's built into this money is
a lot better cleaning of the protease
column so you get a lot for you are
from from ghost signals and other things
there is a price and the price is you
have to have a pump that can pick pump
1500 gar but those are commercially
available today too so this is the
laboratory this is not all my work I
have other people that have helped me
you saw a long list of authors on the
name on the first part of this talk but
the people who work with me at NIST who
make this all possible Arianna care of
Jonas Karl Anderson Alesia Gallagher who
is now an assistant professor of Baylor
Jun Philippine helped with statistical
work and Travis Gallagher helped with
the structural work of the
crystallography section and thank you
for listening to my webinar thank you
dr. Hudgens for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and will address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email okay so let's get started our
first question is when two proteins
undergo a binding interaction do they
always exhibit decreased deuterium
uptake that's the answer to that
question is a quick answer is no at the
point of the interaction between the two
proteins where they're actually binding
you'll usually see almost always see a
reduction as shown in that examples I
present it but where are you with where
that you can get allosteric interactions
a events where other parts of the
protein will loosen up the biggest
perfect example of this is is that
hemoglobin or myoglobin which binds with
iron when the iron binds you'll see a
reduction of the deuterium exchange
around the binding site of the iron but
on the outside the protein acts
loosens up and this causes additional
deuterium exchange on the outside and
this is actually important for drug
discovery because you can use you can
there's other examples where you can
actually see allosteric interactions of
a of a drug lead with the target that
you're actually going for thank you for
that looks like we have time for just
one more question so it is is the lipid
removal system limited to HDX MS
experiments removal is commonly needed
for a lot of things where you would want
to do chromatography and so if you're 10
if your method needs a needs a part of
the workflow to being removal of a lipid
this this will work fine you can do it
automated and you can buy manual
crushers which will still work faster
than the spend-down method that that is
currently that was used in the
literature before we introduced that and
you can buy those and those still are
faster than to use and then using a
spend-down method or separation and that
i would like to once again thank dr.
Hudgens for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January
25th 2019 you'll receive an email from
laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues may have missed today's event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon bye